el horror de lm 17 quedó grabado para
siempre en la memoria de harbaugh
fue aquí justo en las afueras de este
pueblo donde el vuelo de malaysia
airlines terminó derrumbado el 17 de
julio de 2014
el avión fue alcanzado por un misil
buque matando a las 298 personas a bordo
algunos residentes todavía están
obsesionados con ese día cuando llegamos
al lugar del accidente había una mancha
de sangre en medio de la carretera no
podíamos verla desde lejos pero cuando
nos acercamos vimos las piernas de un
humano hasta la cintura y un cadáver
colgando en cables que el vuelo despegó
de ámsterdam y 196 de las víctimas eran
ciudadanos ni grandes es casi que países
bajos se le encomendó la tarea de
liderar la investigación
después de 15 meses del equipo
internacional de investigadores concluyó
que una ojiva de fabricación rusa volada
con el misil book fue lanzada desde la
parte del este de ucrania controlada por
los rebeldes para derribar el avión dos
años después en mayo de 2018 australia y
países bajos culparon públicamente a
rusia por el incidente esto después de
que descubrieron que el sistema de
misiles pertenecía a una base militar
rusa en la ciudad de cursos
moscú ha negado con vehemencia toda
participación en 2019 se acusó a cuatro
soldados de los rusos igor here king
sergej dubinsky y old school a top y un
ucraniano leonid tkachenko todos tienen
vínculos con grupos rebeldes respaldados
por rusia hoy la fiscalía pidió cadena
perpetua por asesinato y derribo
intencional en un juicio que comenzó en
marzo del año pasado en países bajos los
cuatro sospechosos se negaron a
comparecer ante el tribunal y fueron
juzgados en ausencia